hi good afternoon I'm Michelle Larew
Bustamante I'm here to talk to you about
surviving microservices and I might like
Game of Thrones I'm just going to throw
that out there so what I'm gonna do is
take you through a tour I do a lot of
this day-to-day with my team with our
customers
designing micro services deploying them
predictor production dealing with all of
the trouble and complexity and so I
pulled this together as a story of kind
of summing up the things that will help
you along your journey if you were to go
down this road from the beginning of the
design phase to getting to production
hopefully safely so that's what I do
date today and hopefully I can share a
few tips with you so let's start with a
message and that is well we're gonna
talk about micro services but I'm gonna
lead with most of you might not need
micro services and the reason that I say
that as an intro is that people take the
principles of micro services obviously
very seriously and you'll start going
down the road of design and then you'll
realize while I have to make some
choices and they're tough choices right
I have really usually I can only pick
with this you know with the cheap fast
and good I can usually only pick two
right when you think about software
development but the reality with micro
services is it's even harder because it
has to be good because if you don't do
it right you don't do it well you won't
survive it you literally will not be
able to you know keep your production up
and running so you need to invest in
this process and therefore it will not
be fast because you got things to learn
new development procedures new waste new
workflows within the development cycle
and the DevOps cycle new tools and it's
not gonna be cheap because that means
you have to invest in that with team
member or bodies maybe some consulting
experts people that help you along your
way to get the first MVP launched and so
with all that good news
maybe let's just say that when you're
going to go down the road of doing
microservices you need to play to win or
you'll fail so how do we play to win
what do we do to survive this process
well first of all maybe make good
choices so if you're gonna make poor
uneducated decisions and just kind of
say hey it looks like microservice is a
good idea let's build a bunch of little
things and throw them up in the cloud
it'll all work right I think so but you
know he doesn't make it spoiler alert
but if you gather knowledge take your
time try to make good choices take the
time to do the first MVP right and you
know do the learning that it takes well
then you'll probably make it and by the
way this one has dragons and I don't
know about you but if I was in
production with micro-services I kind of
want the ones with the Dragons
protecting them so I think we run with
that so the way to survive the things
that I've pulled out here have nothing
to do with something that you'll read in
a book that will say here are all the
principles here the things you have to
do this is a little bit more specific
this is a concrete set of things that
I've personally chosen around the things
that I see struggles faced the most
which is in the process of why choosing
if you should even do this in the
process of design and development
troubleshooting things like eventual
consistency in messaging and then
integration and launch because those are
the final steps to go live so I'm just
going to kind of go attack this one by
one but what I'm gonna do is focus on
this with in mind that you would do all
of these things for even an MVP so to
survive why why do you want to do
microservices question number one and
there's a lot of really bad reasons to
you know you'll see all these things the
internet will always prove concepts of
you know what people are doing out there
and therefore it must be good right like
doc doc er adoption
container platform adoption and you know
all kinds of momentum behind it you know
you don't want to be left behind and
those are not good reasons to do it
because the reality is you're not them
you have to make these choices for your
business and it is all about your
business but wait there's more there's
all kinds of really bad reasons for
example marketing right you think hey
I'm gonna throw the word microservices
on our product you know that's gonna
probably sell more isn't that a great
idea you know
hashtag containers hashtag services
everything not gonna work
mono lista micro-services it must be the
only way right if we're gonna leave the
model if we have to go all-in and that's
just not necessarily true because you
could just do a really bad job at that
as well from the previous time and of
course developers like it so if they're
pushing from the developer side hey yes
we got to do this is really important
the business still has to help decide is
this really the right fit for us so
probably not you know the best way to
choose because it doesn't pay the bills
and containers are fund whatever so the
thing is throwing containers and
throwing microservices at the problem
doesn't necessarily solve the monolithic
issue no more than you throw drag is on
fire and that will automatically mean
that you're gonna have some dragons and
they're gonna be like your children but
what you do want to do when you think
about microservices the first and most
important thing you can do is as a
business with the technology team with
the stakeholders in the business
understand you know what is it about
moving to micro services that will align
better the release of features for
example you know what are good reasons
to do micro services are there things
we're struggling with such as you know
rapid releases of features are we having
trouble doing that with confidence you
know is there something we can do that
will make it a little bit easier more
isolated and more predictable do we want
to improve the system's resiliency and
in the process adopt these modern tools
that help make that work better and
maybe at least start heading in that
direction as a rule and as a process as
a company do we need more visibility
into operation
it's even not just instrumentation but
also the business so we're by something
like messaging might be useful because
we can have now visibility of activities
across cross-cutting across different
application solutions even off-the-shelf
products into the whole business
operation so that business people can do
their job better do we want to maybe
incorporate
a distributive you know group of
developers to where each developer could
use the right tool for the job not
because they know not just because they
know it better but also because maybe
it's the best tool for the job but still
have the same deployment experience
which means containers those are good
reasons having heterogeneous teams also
useful right so I think when we think
about being able to have that
flexibility it can add value now all of
the tools that come in the micro
services you know space right now
support this right we have containers
containers make that encapsulation
easier that predictability more easier
the platform's help us with deployment
and management and self-healing of the
operations certainly there's tooling
around that that's tangential around
operations instrumentation visibility
dashboards and so on so all these
operational practices that kind of go
with the mantra of micro services are
the things that help you to be
successful and then there are the design
principles which you know also help
inform how we tease apart the monolith
but that being said again all of these
reasons that might be good to go to my
cursors for example around adding
features more quickly releasing with
confidence still really don't mean
anything until you've aligned that with
what is your business problem right now
and so when we think about each of these
potential reasons why micro services is
helpful to me as a company we have to
take that and map it to valuable things
in our business right so thinking about
for example not being able to meet
customer demands for features okay so a
rapid release cycle with smaller things
that don't stomp on other things that
don't get in the way
regression testing or introduced
problems that's a really good reason to
consider going into that direction
releases are filled with risk okay so
how do we improve that again the tooling
the ability to do roll backs more easily
and self-heal the the solution so then
we get into well container platforms do
provide some of that right so is that
going to help us over time if we start
moving in this way people have trouble
sometimes tracking down things that go
wrong in the whole operation of the
business with off-the-shelf products
back-end systems synchronization of
databases people have workflows you know
maybe order and fulfillment procedures
that hit not just customers from the
website but also back-end fulfillment
and I can give you an example I've had
some customers you know literally where
developers are the ones being called
when something's not in the place it
should be because they need to hunt down
did that file drop happen did the thing
that processes the file get it into the
mainframe did the synchronization job
happen after that where did we land and
why isn't it here you know that's a good
reason to move forward with you know a
new solution that might include say
messaging right so that we can now start
building dynamic workflows around the
state of what's going on across all
these different solutions and then you
know DevOps dual tools and having more
consistency there if you have different
types of products that you're deploying
across the ecosystem of your
applications for customers and
back-office managing those in a
consistent way means investing in maybe
one type of orchestration platform that
you can really just learn to do well and
start getting better dashboards and
instrumentation and security and not
have to have this polyglot sort of
situation where you're trying to cover
too much ground but none of this means
anything until you match it to dollar
value because if the business is not
going to see something of benefit after
the first MVP goes live then all the
money you spent to do that is just going
to go down the drain because they're
going to say this is too expensive
how do we know the next release won't be
just as expensive and I got nothing so
the number one thing you can do to
survive why is really take a step back
and think about what is it that the
business needs in order to survive right
in order to you know I guess make it
worthwhile to spend the money to adopt
these news practices to spend this time
on this first launch okay so that's the
number one thing so once we've figured
out yes there are some business drivers
and maybe we've even identified a POC or
an MVP that will make a great first
launch or some idea of a problem that we
want to solve that at least those would
be where we're going to identify the
first services to go when we get to that
point now we have to survive design and
design is hard right because you know
well it's always hard right software's
hard takes time but it's so important
when we start digging into this new
ecosystem of micro services because you
know you want to plan for the future you
want to position yourself to be
successful into the future and so to
survive design I like to take you
through maybe a couple of high-level
steps that seem to help in terms of
teasing out you know what are the moving
parts of the system and then we're going
to marry that too what are the things we
really want to solve so for example the
first thing you're gonna do probably is
say what are our main business domains
right so you want to go to the top level
and say okay well we have you know these
different things in our system we have
product catalog and recommendations
engine so maybe we sell things online
there's a shopping cart
there's payments and orders obviously so
we need different solutions for those
things we have a supply chain management
maybe in fulfillment for product
shipping and sales think like an Amazon
or something like that and then we've
got you know customer relation
management customer support you know
these are all tools software some of
them front facing some of them back
office some of them part of different
divisions of the org and of course
somewhere in their identity management
people have to log in people have to
call API securely they have to manage
their SSO
integrate with other provider so there's
different features right that live in
each of these boxes and the first thing
you're gonna do is say okay well done I
think we found our domain so each of
those boxes is a micro service right but
that depends and so now we got to open
up the the box of maybe one of these
domains and say ok well let's take a
look at you know five six use cases and
try to tease out what do users really do
in here and let's take identity as an
example because it's something we all
know right we all log in places we know
what logging in means we know user
management so the first thing I might
see is that there's user single sign-on
and single sign-on is you know I log in
I log out I have a session maybe it
takes me over to somewhere else to login
like my Google account or or a DFS but
the point is there's a set of features
in here that make sense
in identity and there's a user object
which is probably my aggregate the next
thing I have is user management create
users activate/deactivate users maybe
there's other features of the user
unlock the user if there's for some
reason the need to do an immediate
unlock and instead of a timeout so these
are things that happen with a different
UI different sort of set of users are
interacting but there's still a user
domain it's a user object it's got an ID
and a you know a password probably and
maybe relationship to other logins and
then we have user self-service self
registration workflows confirm my email
forgot my password change my email
confirm the new one that kind of
workflow where I might have a whole set
of UI around that kind of feature maybe
it's even linked to profile in some ways
and then we've got permissions which is
what am I allowed to do in all these
apps
so the first three talk about users I
might start thinking well that's just
that's a micro service then write the
whole set of user things but maybe
permissions we can start to see it's a
different aggregate it's a different set
of data right it's related to users but
it's sort of got its own management
story its own life cycle for features
and then we might have a user profile
that in some cases is just a first name
and a last name in the
database and in other cases is a very
rich you know profile with you know
links to accounts and dashboards and
things I'm allowed to do in the
ecosystem of this product for example so
we're looking for does identity which we
first thought was just one big domain
maybe have a few domains inside that we
can isolate based on the premise of you
know what is the lifecycle for change
when I change how we manage permissions
does that affect identity
no so I can probably safely make that a
smaller set of micro services same with
profile if I have profile and dashboards
and accounts and things like that
then it makes sense that maybe that
should be a separate one so this is the
way of thinking we start big we drill
into some use cases we learn about the
use cases and then we tease it out but
we need to do that for all those big
domains to sort of start really thinking
out of the box because the last thing
you want to do is say I already know the
system here's the breakdown that's a
very technology oriented way to
determine your domains the real way is
to think about the user in the
stakeholder how are people using these
parts of the system and do they have a
separate life cycle for potentially
deployment updates feature requests and
so on and this is just identity and
we've already found three you can
imagine the rest of your system how even
customers and orders might have
completely different front ends and life
cycles to manage it even though they all
work with a piece of order or customer
data so keep an open mind go through the
process tease out your aggregates and
with the aggregates of course what we're
looking for our single transaction
updates to that datastore so that the
micro service can own its data and so
when we look at it this way the user for
example is related to permissions and
profile and the rule of DDD is that that
would just be related by its identifier
but there's no either cross over a
single transaction update for any
particular method call updates the
aggregate within and that would be
what's owned by the service and each
service may or may not have multiple
aggregates
but an aggregate never appears in more
than one service so it's owned so once
we get through this process now we're
thinking about okay look I'm an
architect or a developer I've been at
the company 20 years I know exactly how
it works in and out upside down we need
to sit down in a room and start going to
the whiteboard and thinking about this
micro-services breakdown and
the process for doing that is you know
like maybe in a week you could sit at
the whiteboard and get a lot done get
through like you know that three to five
use cases for somewhere up to ten
domains and really start teasing out
what does this feel like it's gonna head
towards in terms of architecture but
then another interesting thing happens
I've done this before where I've gone
and talked to people and and and you
know it's time-consuming right to sit
and talk and ask about these use cases
and they kind of just want to be done
because they say well you know I already
know like this is how this is gonna work
and I said well you know what I don't
know the domain so let me just answer
quest
you some questions let's gather and we
start to gather and I say you know when
you get the business you know
stakeholders in the room so we can
understand how they're using this UI I
already know how they use it you know we
we basically you know have been working
on this for twenty years like I said I
know it inside out and then I'll get to
a point where I'll say well why couldn't
we do this or how does this work and
then they'll say you know what we need
to bring so-and-so in the room and this
true story we sit in the room and we go
through the question again and this
stakeholder comes in it says well the
only reason we do it that way is because
the UI doesn't let us do this so this is
what I really want to do this is the
workflow I want and so now we've just
uncovered because we included all the
right people
actual use cases so the worst that you
can do is think that you know everything
just because you worked at the company
for you know 20 years
take a step back keep an open mind and
obviously we don't want to work with
someone who knows nothing so what we
shoot for is somewhere in the middle you
know keep an open mind try to go through
these use cases take the patience it
takes to do so talk to the stakeholders
and learn what do they really need and
that's how you're going to find your
domains and that's how you're going to
learn you know orders over here is for
these types of users that manage orders
this way and
over here is for a completely different
purpose and that could be a different
micro-service and as far as the
relationship between that data don't
even think about that until you get
through this first part because then
we'll deal with how we deal with the
data issues so when we take this step
back what we're trying to do is break
Conway's law right or actually follow
Conway's law in a better way with our
solution which is you know the way the
organization wants to work with the
applications is the true domain so your
software should reflect that
otherwise the the users the end users
are going to end up being
compartmentalized in the way that your
technology of you looks so we want to go
the opposite direction so that we can
improve and that's the goal now design
doesn't stop there
now we have to think about things like
what is a service and how big is a
service and what does it own in terms of
the data so let's take identity again I
know behind most identity systems with
identity server we have a config API and
we have a runtime API for login login
owns the user's config owns the config
data and that all makes sense so now I
have two micro services but then we deal
with things like well I have this UI for
configuring the system and then I have
this other UI for managing the web and
then I have this other UI for
self-service but you know they can call
those micro services and that would be
fine
maybe a wouldn't scale for 2 million
users maybe it would depend on scale so
now we're introducing what are one of
the things that helped me decide how
small my services should be I've already
identified that you know identity web
needs runtime login for sure we know
that but now we need to think about how
far should we go in terms of granularity
so one way to go is to migrate your way
towards this is to maybe build separate
controllers or even separate API is just
for the different views into the data
even though the data is shared and
that's a way to start thinking in terms
of interfaces these methods belong in
this service these are different you
know contracts if you will into that
data and of course right now I still
only have two my
services because they're sharing the
domain which means this is the unit of
deployment they all own the same data
they all work together and when I update
one you know when I deploy these they go
together basically right it's got the
same lifecycle but what if I have 20
million users
what if runtime needs to be fully
optimized and maybe I don't want to be
sharing the same data store for those
things what if the lifecycle of updating
user management or self-service actually
needs to be done by a different division
of the company and we need them to have
their own autonomy so now we're getting
into well maybe I need full stack
isolation and maybe I need each of these
to be a service and the first thing
you're gonna say is well but how do I
deal with that data issue don't think
about that yet you have to stop yourself
and say I know I'll work that out let's
just pretend for the moment that we know
that whatever it is I do behind each of
these micro services can be fully
isolated so each of them own their own
data and now we've got you eyes that
match nicely and it's starting to look
like a bit of a clean solution so we're
making progress it's not achievement
unlocked yet there's more to do but it's
a start and so now we deal with the data
problem how do I make sure that if I am
locking a user or deactivating in the
management or adding my new registration
over here that all of the other data
stores eventually know about it and the
answer is of course eventual consistency
so not that you're gonna do it at the
data tier but that's the thing we need
to happen right new user created it's
got to produce a user so they can log in
eventually it gets their users
deactivated it's got it eventually and
eventually it means milliseconds right
if everything's running smoothly then we
we make sure that the user can't log in
anymore because the is active fly gets
turned off so we trust that we can get
here we haven't talked about how yet but
with that story I can keep this purity
of separate micro services and go to
this level of granularity and therefore
these can scale to whatever they need to
scale to which might be different and
they can be updated to whatever the
lifecycle of demand
is by our business units without a
problem these are good things okay so
now achievement unlocked sort of we've
got this idea of these granular micro
services we think we kind of have teased
out the right domains and and even
experiences in the UI and business users
and we still doesn't have to think
closely what is a micro service because
the micro service is supposed to have
one job it's supposed to fit in your
head it's supposed to be small enough
but that doesn't mean it is only one
service entirely it means that it is a
unit of deployment like a pod you know
in kubernetes it is a unit of deployment
that will always be deployed together
even if not all the things changed
probably it shares the same aggregate of
course but that doesn't mean that it
always is only one container or one
service and the reason I bring that up
is just because you know the whole idea
of the principles of micro services are
nuanced and sometimes you run into these
things and you go but I'm breaking the
principles what am I gonna do now and
you know what you have to get over that
that's all I'm gonna say so it depends
and it's okay so is it one micro service
probably not because I have config and
users that's obvious is it two micro
services I don't know maybe depending on
if I'm going to break down the data on
the back end and also depending on
whether or not they should just all be
part of a unit and it is easy to love a
theory with all of these things but Jim
counts I work with and he said it one
day and I said I'm gonna totally steal
that so you know the theories of
principles and micro service but the end
of the day you're gonna be in a room
together with people and you're gonna
have to make these tough decisions and
you know what you gotta move on because
you've got to get something done and
you're gonna want to you know you can
have these strong principles where
you're following everything by the law
and you can also have no principles and
just do whatever you feel like and be a
cowboy and probably none of those work
out too well so how about somewhere in
the
all right try your best to follow the
microservices principles and then you
know get something live because you know
what you're never gonna stop refactoring
we don't like on refactor code recode
has to be constantly touched to keep it
current to keep it reviewed every time I
review a piece of code or in
architecture there's always something we
can do a little bit better a little bit
different get to a good point and move
along
okay so we've survived the business
knows why we're doing this we have a
goal to reach we've gone through design
and in the process learned a little bit
about the whole system hopefully just as
many parts as we can so we can find some
patterns for the growth into the future
and then we tease out of that the thing
that will satisfy the business in this
first eight month period that we're
going to release something because that
thing we do in eight months if it
doesn't satisfy something that helps the
business then you might end up throwing
out everything unless the business is
committed to this you know unequivocally
even after spending all the money and
spending all the time they want to see
business results make sure you focus on
that tease the right thing out and now
we focus on how do we survive the
development phase so surviving
development it really just means you
know making sure that early on we're
adopting practices that help us be
productive and help us achieve the goals
right and one of those things of course
I'm a huge fan of is the fact that
docker makes containerization so
accessible in development it's helpful
and of course throughout the whole
DevOps lifecycle it's helpful and then
it plays well into the container
platforms but the number one thing I
will tell you that I really highly
recommend you do is the ability to take
your source all of the services you're
building and working on and you know
essentially those repositories will have
their compose files each API each web
app each projector whatever those assets
are and you will be able to compose up
that whole environment so that I could
onboard new developers and say hey to
install docker get pull compose up and
you can see the whole solution running
so that's one thing to do the other
thing is dependencies on the cloud so
even just recently I
we were working with a group that you
know struggling to have environments
that are ready in in Amazon or Azure
that are in a situation with the right
data in them that we can just onboard
somebody quickly to fix up one API or
one web app that they never worked with
before and now we've got this whole set
up like that we have to go through just
to be productive enough to make a change
in a piece of code that we don't usually
work on and you know the way to get
around that one would be of course you
could just make sure that all these
environments so you could spin up a new
environment in in the cluster with the
database back-end and the initialized
data and have some scripts for all that
but you know that's hard it's hard
enough to just do automation in the
cloud for your environments that you
need to manage for you know test and UAC
and prod so reality is you could just
invest some time as a developer and
bypass all that nonsense and compose up
all the dependencies and even compose up
initialization containers that will put
some data into these right single line
of code compose up and that instruction
gets you on boarded and up and ready and
now I go to visual studio to edit the
one thing I wanted to change that can
hit these local configurations and do
the job so invest in that because it's
well worth it number one tip and you
know at the end of that for the identity
solution that might mean that all of
these things run in containers I've got
a Postgres container so everything with
a shadow is a container and you know the
Postgres container gets initialized with
some script so that I can have a seeded
set of users or configuration settings
for the environment and I'm good to go
so absolutely that and then of course we
know that it works on your machine and
it will probably also work in the cloud
so when you're testing you can do a
compose up and see that your stuffs
working with containers and then of
course when the container image is built
in your CI CD process that will just go
to your cloud deployment now speaking of
that of course we know that when we
build containers we need to or when we
you know write our source and we're
building our container images that we're
probably going to want to build those
images
and test locally but then push them up
to a registry so manually on my command
line I can just build the image and then
I can manually push it to a registry and
I'm gonna tag those images with whatever
makes sense but usually it's the latest
one I build is you guessed it latest
that's great and then I'm gonna have
tags for maybe product releases or
commit identifiers or something of that
nature so other labels and you can
automate that with your CI CD so when I
commit into you know github or VST s I
can have a build step that will take the
source pull the latest build the image
push the image to the container registry
and then of course that gets tagged you
could automate the tagging etc etc so
once we have that now we have an issue
of okay so what is the importance of
tagging why are we even talking about
this in terms of my life cycle of
survival as developer and the answer is
I've had developers where they've
committed some images to a master branch
and guess what went to production latest
because somebody didn't know that you
never put latest in production unless
you really are committing on the right
branch and you really do have a full CI
CD process ready to go and these guys
didn't so latest went to production and
things were not going well and they
figured out what happened not right away
because that was a weird problem right
so somebody just didn't realize that
latest was being pulled in production so
the rule of thumb I like to give people
is until you really are 100% for sure CI
CD master branch and have better control
over all your peeps I would say why
don't we just say Deb gets latest and
that's my cloud deployment for testing
and everything else has a specific tag
and that's what we pull and if that one
tip is the one that you take away from
today you're welcome so one day that'll
matter next thing what about
repositories oh my goodness another
dilemma I'm and I'm in development and
I've got all these micro services should
I have one solution but that's not a
micro service right here's the thing the
goal is one
posit or e1 service dockerfile
done but that's hard to do right because
if you're safe you people working on a
new project let's just say identity
server solution and there's 25 projects
that need to be loaded because it's a
micro service solution with events and
messaging and lots of little running
around you know front ends and API
middle tiers and backends maybe it's not
so productive until we've got a baseline
to separate it into those repos don't
get overwhelmed with that stuff you need
to be productive you need to get stuff
done but what you need to remember are
the principles why we separate the
repository and that is we don't want to
share code the whole purpose of micro
services is that I'm not going to
accidentally build a new release for a
different service and get some update to
an assembly because we were sharing
assembly updates like that need to be
very carefully controlled so I'll talk
about that but in the meantime just
speaking to this you know discussion
single repository per you know can per
service would be ideal you got a docker
file you produce an image and that's the
that's the lay of the land and then
ultimately that's the container that
gets run if you can do this if you can
subscribe to this great it does force
you to think right away about the
sharing of code because now your shared
assemblies are also in a separate repo
which means it's going to be a pain
right to go and create these solutions
that load all the different repositories
into one visual solution to work on but
it's worth the pain if you don't feel
like you have control that later you're
gonna go back and do this because you
know what you kind of don't go with a
separate repository maybe create a joint
solution and then eventually get out of
the habit of the single solution and use
docker files locally compose up for the
stuff you're not working on right now
and only open you know the the
applications that you care about at the
moment shared code is a thing that they
usually frown upon right micro-services
does not it's not a proponent
shared code for the reasons I said
already you don't want to update
accidentally another service there
should be clear boundaries in isolation
between all of these things but you're
gonna have to share a code because what
about API security I don't want to write
that code five million different ways in
fact on the contrary I want that code
written the same way everywhere because
I've seen it where people didn't do that
and they had these oh we're autonomous
okay fine
you're autonomous and now you moved from
one identity provider possibly to
another and guess what somebody didn't
write the code the same way that
identity provider did things a little
bit differently now you have to go
figure out out of all the 300 apps that
you have who's playing nice and who's
not playing nice how about you just
share a library and get things like this
standardized but it's good it could be
shared with a new gift package and then
it's explicit that you opt in and so if
we update the way we do the security and
it's a required update for everybody
you need a procedure for that standard
operating procedures what do we do when
there is a critical fix and all of those
containers should get rebuilt pull the
latest nougat and and that's what you're
testing with otherwise if it's more of a
feature thing and you can opt in when
you're ready then you're not impacting
all this other container standard
operating procedure I have an optional
you know update to this package when I'm
ready to use it I will thank you very
much you didn't affect my container so
prepare to refactor again and again and
again you're not gonna get all of this
right the first time you have to go live
with something so now we can talk about
troubleshooting we've survived design
and then development hopefully some tips
to help you be successful with that
process with some of the common dilemmas
that I see and now we have to talk about
an instrumentation because guess what if
you don't write logs you don't have them
Thank You captain obvious so you have to
start this from the beginning and I
don't mean write logs
oh I installed Siri log everything's
good I mean intentional logs I mean
taking care for
assistant ways for all the apps to
enable logs and thinking through what is
our policy or strategy around logs and
telling developers don't do method entry
logs for goodness sakes it's not useful
so we look for logs so that we can do
things like end-to-end tracing this is
the dream right what I want to be able
to do is I want to have you know an
activity that happens where the user
says hey I'm gonna log in and the first
thing that the system does maybe first
launch is goes to the config and loads
and caches that config gather some
things and then it goes over here and
long to the user in gets their profile
checks if they're active couple of calls
happen and then at the end of all of
that you know we're we're gonna be
logged in and then the eventual
consistency may be some of those
messages around the login or a lockout
activity get played over to audit you
know endpoints or things like that so
that whole thing
the red dots ought to be connected by
something because what I'm looking for
is visibility what I'm looking for is
thinking through right up front that
when I add logs to my solution that when
something happens and goes wrong at a
certain point that I actually can just
click that link check the activity ID
and see all the things that led up to
exactly that and I don't care at that
point in time method entered method
entered HTTP called
know I care about actual concrete things
that happen at each of those points that
were meaningful information logs not
debug not not maybe some debug logs but
mostly it's all about you know
meaningful logs at each point in time so
interesting things happen when you start
to do that now I can see from start of
activity all the way to end of activity
all the things that led up to the error
maybe it's not even an error maybe it's
a message that happened and I want to
inspect something again go to my logs
check the activity get the whole picture
and when you start you know actually
using your logs this way then you
actually discover interesting things
about the meaningfulness
your lungs or lack thereof for example
what about this informative logs
maybe so some logs are actually useful
they mean something happen it could be
an exception it could be something you
know of an activity like user logged in
with sam'l but this is not informative
however it did teach me something that
my error page had an error you know so I
had an object you know some sort of no
passed in and and that actually meant
that my error page didn't have the
information that needed and I saw that
cuz guess what I'm troubleshooting with
my logs because I don't use docker debug
in Visual Studio I actually go and try
to troubleshoot my own stuff with my own
logs because then as a developer I'm
actually helping to reach the goal of
meaningful logs because I'm gonna know
better than anybody right I'm the one
troubleshooting debugging going through
that day-to-day so as soon as I have
enough of a codebase to make that
worthwhile that's what I should be doing
and then I've got weird logs like you
know again method entered completely
useless okay debug with your logs and it
will be something you'll be very
grateful for later you will also start
finding interesting things like oh wow
well of course method enter let's get
rid of those yeah I should clean those
up i I delete those things now when I
see them when I'm working on code bases
and doing code reviews security reviews
I'll just like that's gone out of here
next thing it's you know why am I seeing
three logs of the same thing take a look
at it right clean it up
how about passwords in the logs that's
never happened so you know HIPAA gdpr
lots of reasons to care uh-huh
all right now let's think about
microservices views of logs so
everything being a micro service of
course my logs should include things
like which component I was in which my
cursor vus I'm in whatever meaningful
around that may be what environment I'm
in products cetera etc is it Michelle's
machine or is it Joe's machine and guess
what now you can go to cabana or your
other logging you know infrastructure
and you can start building views of the
micro service itself and then build
aggregate views that
sort of the overall status of a group of
microservices this may be the identity
microservices and then you go up another
level and you have dashboards that show
you know the whole system or a whole
area like a departments worth of
products so you build these dashboards
and they can have these different layers
of views because now you have these
interesting logs and they do go in to
end and they give you good data points
so these things should be happening
early it's a parallel thread you do your
job as a developer to collect the logs
and make them useful and then early on
when you're deploying to your
environments and your orchestration
cluster somebody can start thinking
about views of data and troubleshooting
information and so on because the other
thing we like to do is have developers
all push their logs from their various
machines as they're debugging and
troubleshooting up to a common area
elastic for example and then that way
the person who might be doing the ops
side can actually see those logs and do
something with it and built these
filters of views based on real data
that's actually kind of happening while
we're building the product so it's
really useful next surviving eventual
consistency so I bring this up because a
lot of the solutions that I do I do not
throw messages lightly at a system just
because I'm a fan of the architecture
doesn't mean it fits everywhere but I do
say this if it's a fit for your
architecture because you want messages
to you know get better visibility into a
solution like what's happening in
workflows across the various products
then when you take that intima into
consideration the end result of that is
a lot of powerful things that you can do
with those messages like what I'm going
to talk about so eventual consistency
means that you know when something
changes in say the right store or the
right side I change the configuration it
eventually pops over to the runtime same
thing goes with user and identity and as
you know you probably would expect there
could be a few of these paths that can't
be eventually consistent so those you're
going to have to find a way to go direct
to the to the read store worth worth
mentioning now each of these being
your service owning their own data
eventual consistency on the back using a
message based solution I can pop in
messages out of each of those services
and then with those topics each of them
can be a microservices topic of their
own and then those messages get replayed
into from a projector the data store at
the target okay now with that in mind we
what we're looking for here is now a
vertical that represents the Micra
service which is the API the collection
of messages a message is never repeated
in any other so it's not hard to follow
right you're keeping everything that
fits in your head in the vertical the
micro service fits in my head I have
maybe you know 20 30 messages max I've
got you know an API surface area I have
a projector that knows how to play those
messages and I have a data store that
gets the the rights from that and with
that now I can do really interesting
things like what if I want history and
audit tables so now without writing code
that creates a history table or an audit
table in my mainstream code where the
activity happened I can eventually
project that because I can take these
messages as a source and I can say hey
let's spin up some new projectors pull
those messages from the beginning of
time and now into the future and let's
project our history table for all the
things this user did and who gave them
this permission in that permission and
who took it away and also all the audit
they logged in they logged out etc so we
start to get you know messages that will
represent the flow of things that happen
with the user and it gives us that kind
of sort of for free after investing in
the messaging architecture so messaging
also should fit with your end-to-end
visibility story which means that the ID
of an activity like I started a login
should also include you know that
activity ID through to the projectors
because then we can also do things like
tie in things that happen eventually
with the original request so now I know
this audit table right happens
as part of that users login on that day
and you can tie that all together with
your with your not only with your
messages that you are you know saving
but also with your logs if if applicable
so this gets really interesting right
now when we talk about messages being
now basically so prominent in the
ecosystem of this solution for example
that kind of means the messages are the
source of truth but they're eventually
projecting to the read store so the most
current state of what's happened is
actually the message right so I'm active
or I'm not I got locked out or not that
kind of thing now of course it's not
that easy to write messages to say an
event hub or or a Kinesis or a kafka and
be able to quickly query hey is this
user locked out or not right so there
are tools out there like platforms like
event store where actually the messages
are it's not just a messaging
architecture it's also a store so it
actually represents the user everybody
would have their own user stream for
example in this architecture and that
user you can always ask the aggregate
are you logged in or out because
essentially all the messages play back
to really extremely fast for that stream
so at the moment of login I'm actually
not checking the read store to see if
you can log in I'm checking the actual
stream and it's a it's a special
platform that supports exactly that and
I've seen that done with other messaging
architectures you know colleagues of
mine who have implemented that but
that's just harder to do and you know
this is built from the beginning to do
that so I'd say if you're looking for
what's called an event sourcing
architecture this is your go-to it's
another way to solve the same problem
and what that means is the messages are
actually building a stream and the
projectors are still reading the stream
all the same and the difference is that
you know now we have a central way to
manage
a central way to ask the the current
state now this starts to look like one
microservice right again it could be it
could be in the sense that they're
sharing an aggregate in the middle so
this is where we get back into the you
know again this will scale wildly
because everybody has their own user
stream so there's no contention right
multiple threads etc but it starts to
look like this is one aggregate and now
we get into that original problem I said
which is we have design decisions to
make move along make the decision you'll
refactor later if it sucks so surviving
integration this is really interesting
because microcircuit
I mean obviously going to have a lot of
little services running around and we're
gonna need to have unit tests for each
of those every micro-service fitting in
your head suddenly makes it really easy
to write a reasonable number of unit
tests for every single one of these
services right so maybe we can have some
better practices as a development team
and also to automate running those tests
in a container to hit the service as you
as you commit and have your build
process of the image take it through
that process automatically right
associate your unit tests with that and
it's all again fits in your head every
micro service manageable amount but
there is another really interesting
thing that micro services asks us to do
in terms of principles and that is we
speak about consumers of the your
service providing the test cases and
this is really important because I don't
know if anybody has ever written test
cases or written to unit tests for a
service and then found that somebody
uncovered a way that that service could
be used that you weren't expecting
so I can write my unit test for how I
expect you to write the method but maybe
I don't realize that when we create
users over here that there's this
back-end process that's going to bypass
the you know the password protection and
maybe produce a different record for a
user with grandfather passwords that
don't match our policy the new policy or
the workflow they're going to go in
they're going to
enable automatically confirm the email
even though they didn't go through the
email process and I didn't realize that
that could be a use case so how do we
discover those things well anybody using
my microservice right should be able to
say we're gonna call it from this app in
this way and we're gonna call it from
this app in this way and I should be
able to collect all that as information
to the requirements for my testing so my
unit testing you know that's all fine
and well but what I want is integration
testing that won't blow up right so I'm
looking for a solution which means you
got to help me know how are you going to
use my service so that we don't end up
with something like this which would be
really bad yeah now surviving the launch
so I've instrumented everything
beautifully we've got logs I've debugged
with them they're awesome
and I've got unit tests and integration
tests and everybody's done their job and
this is all a lot of work right design
all the way through the development new
tooling etc deploying automatically
latest to a development environment
maybe a test environment so we can test
and get used to running the platform
right and now we're going to go live so
how do we prepare for that go live write
your solutions in the middle and these
are all your users they're going to hit
you know the next day because you're a
startup who knows you're gonna be wildly
popular like Pinterest and in just a day
and have 20 million users that will
crash you down or not or you already
have 20 million users and you know that
you have to prepare for that right away
so all these things are possible and
ultimately what we're saying is you know
when you hit the button to go live go to
production just imagine there's somebody
out there saying prepare to fail right
because you got to be ready to roll back
you got to be ready to roll forward you
got to have standard operating
procedures for solving problems and the
only way that you know you need to do
those things is by actually making an
effort to make it fail already so when
you decide to go live
you've got your automation for the
infrastructure and and all of that
deployment of the containers and
of that but we need to try to break the
solution and so the idea here is you
create drills try to tip containers try
to you know load them up and it's not
just load testing it's other stuff kill
containers in the in the solution and
see if they come back take a node out
and see if the containers redistribute
turn off Redis turn off one of your data
stores what happens you know
does everything blow up or or not you
got to try these things put a message
that's bad in the in the event hub you
got to have these drills try them out
and then you've got a document the
standard operating procedures around how
to solve problems like maybe one of your
drill surfaces that after a period of
time running in the environment one of
your nose gets too many images and disk
is full and nothing's deploying so a
standard operating procedure would be
how do we get into the box and look at
the nodes what's the procedure for that
you need those things documented and
ready so that somebody who's trying to
solve a problem can go do it or where do
I go to find these events or these
messages or where's my dashboard for
this and this and this those are the
things you're building and refining and
perfecting during this process of just
pre go live to see how far you can take
it and break it so it's it's basically
you know it's a process that takes
effort and somebody's going to put
latest in production so I'm just gonna
mention that one again and say don't do
it it's a full-time job looking for
things to fail or ways to fail and you
need to put that time in to try to fail
so that you can learn what are the
things I should know about managing that
situation and once you've accepted that
you can have those flaws they can't be
used against you it's a beautiful thing
so with that we talked about at the
beginning that it has to be good and so
we need to survive all of these things
that I've called out in order to make
sure that we're doing all of the
procedures and following some level of
guidance to be successful yes
and also accept that it can't be perfect
it has to be good yes let's call it
great fast not going to be fast cheap
not going to be cheap
why because you have to invest in that
first eight months because that first
launch has to satisfy the business and
the thing that they wanted to solve the
problem they wanted to solve it has to
be impactful so that they say this was
totally worth it and you need to spend
the time that it takes to get there
which means people resources money
possibly trainings new tools expertise
consulting all of it but you invest in
that upfront and now you're ready really
for the growth right the first launch is
going to have a couple of services
solving that one main problem
exponentially from there you'll start to
increase the number of services that you
are able to release and deploy and
manage because you did so many good
things and right things upfront and I
will throw out there just as a swag that
a POC is probably you know like a quick
POC that just does that basic
architecture without it being the full
implementation you could spend you know
six to twelve weeks and you could spend
some money on that with resources right
and just get something done quick so
that you can see okay this is the
platform this is the messaging
architecture here's how messages work
etc etc as an example and then you're
going to spend probably up to eight
months to go live and you're gonna spend
lots of resources on that because of
products and tooling and training and
all of the things people bodies they
cost money
cuz you'll need more people probably
right new people or or consulting one of
those things is going to happen and then
you get to start real risk you know
taking measurable benefits from that
investment and I'm just throwing numbers
up here I want you to know that these
are examples from just looking at a
smattering of different situations
across people I work with and and and
teams that that I've seen go through
this process even internally as
businesses right with their own
resources so just keep those things in
mind remember that it's costly to do it
so make sure you choose the right
reasons
to do it so the business can say this
was worth it and with that I would just
say the answer to the question can you
survive microservices would basically be
if some of these pieces of advice are
things that you follow I think you can
and then you will be prepared for winter
thank you he's scary